his entire relationship with me has been
one long audition for book-smart and he
nailed it it's the last day we got you
through high school I need to go van
with your budget numbers
can't we just graduate head off to
college that's directing him are you
able to easily take off the personal hat
and put on the professional hat how did
that work I mean not completely like
it's still there's still a shorthand
that comes from being someone's closest
partner but I loved being able to just
kind of like set him free because he's
one of the best improvisers in the world
and I just loved that we got him to take
this bit of information we had in the
script and run with it and he gave us so
much I mean we were dying laughing
behind the monitor the whole time I was
like this is remarkable how many people
can do that um
and I loved in the scenes with him our
girls our two leads beany and Caitlin
are just looking at him like how is he
doing that master it is crap yeah
honestly yeah we will persist I can't
hear you I can't soundproof glass we're
the kids with you guys did you make it a
family affair on set you know I think
for every working mother that's the
balance right figuring out how much you
can bring your kids to work and how much
it will distract you and I know there's
a lot of mom guilt out there thinking
about like shouldn't I be able to do it
all at the same time and do it all
perfectly and you can't it's a balance
so I shot four weeks of nights on
book-smart I would come home at 7:00
a.m. get the kids up make them breakfast
get them ready take them to school and
then just like melt just collapse and
that's not something I could do for a
sustained period of time but for this
moment I was like this is my dream come
true I get to direct a movie I'm gonna
give it my all and make it work and I
imagine it's important to you to show
them that mom is a boss that's right
that is right
to show them follow your dreams and go
for it and be brave she's got a really
cute smile go talk to her you've told
the story how you had your friend go up
to Jason and give your phone number oh
yeah what is your advice to girls who
are pining for a crush and don't
necessarily know what they're doing I
mean you had the cop my advice is go be
awesome just be awesome and the right
people will be attract
to you for who you are so I also think
you know if you do admire someone just
know that you being yourself completely
is what will draw them to you not as
sharp as your
[Music]